yeah i expected it to go up but not by
this level yeah um you know there's
still a lot of talk now property prices
are going to crash i just can't see it
especially in this country there may be
certain areas where it does
but there's a housing shortage
absolutely that all the properties that
i've had have rented out before we've
even advertised yeah now people are
asking me people are paying over the
over the odds for them
because they just can't get them
so
simon property investor how many
properties do you own now so we've
currently got four four
and another one going through soon okay
and some of these as well are quite
impressive properties you know you've
got like your hmo you've got your chapel
on the beach
which is which is really exciting so why
don't you just what i really want to get
get from this is how you manage to buy
your properties how you find them how
you structure them tax implications i
know you've got hmos struggle to get a
mortgage um for
for html to begin with so why don't you
talk about your first deal back in 2016
what was your very first property you
bought and what was it that meant you
buy that one yeah so the the first
property i bought back in 2016 was a
derelict three-bed semi-detached house
at the time a few years before i'd been
made redundant from work so i had some
cash you know and i wanted to invest it
um at the time there was myself and my
father he came in 50 50 with me
we bought the property and at that time
i had no real property knowledge or
understand of different strategies
um so we thought the best thing to do is
to buy a house
fix the house and sell it for a profit
yeah
traditional homes and other amazon
exactly exactly yeah
so it went really well a lot of the work
we've done ourselves uh
both in full-time work again by that
point
uh it took us just over a year um
purchased the property for 250.
um we made 70 grand on it which was
really good yeah really good and that
was back in 2016. 2016. at that point
did you is that the point when you
realize there is good money in this this
is what i want to start doing
professionally yeah definitely um
you know i've always been interested in
property but it's understanding the
different strategies behind that now
it's really interesting because 2016 we
purchased the house
um done the house up and obviously sold
it for a good profit i didn't touch
property again until 2020.
i actually went back to university and
done a degree in business on the
weekends wow
what did you use to do that
well it's really interesting so i've
been working in engineering and i wanted
to almost diversify
i think i've always been interested in
business as well and i think the
business was something that sort of
um
sort of helped me with my career but
also gave me a platform into property to
understand the business side of it you
know how to set up a company
how to do the accounts
um strategy accounting planning project
management it sort of covered it all
which was really helpful how much did
your degree cost you that did you get
your business degree well it was
actually sponsored by the company
and so for me i paid in time yeah um
which was the weekends so yeah i i
saw a few videos of yourself online um
know a few academy members that have
gone through the training as well yeah
uh they were real inspiration like some
of the projects they've done are massive
who
did you see on the academy what was it
my good friend is darren and ella from
delaware estates yeah so i used to go to
school with darren they've been on
windows on a wednesday they have yeah
they have yeah and they've done some
really good really interesting things
and still are now very very definitely
yeah so yeah i think they were a real
inspiration to be honest with you yeah
so you saw their winners on a wednesday
interview and you knew them
i did yeah you were just like man this
is awesome okay so 2020 that was when we
met what changed them in terms of
strategy and in terms of property
knowledge and stuff what sort of thought
happening yeah so it was really
interesting so i um i obviously couldn't
attend any live events you weren't doing
them at the time yeah so it was all
online training
so i almost indulged myself in
everything hmo service accommodation
rent to rent deal sourcing and come out
of it a little bit confused i was like
whoa all these different things what do
i do with it now
so i decided to go down the hmo option
yeah so i was looking in the area um and
a bit further afield for hmo
uh found a nice hmo but unfortunately
couldn't get a mortgage on it because i
didn't have any um landlord experience
which was frustrating
house you haven't ever rented it out i
know and looking back on that one in
2016 i wish i kept it and rented it out
you know i could have refinanced it
pulled the money out
um
but there we go we move on but could you
not have like just bought a slightly
smaller html and rented out room by room
or
were you was the one that you'd found
was it quieter well i wanted a big one
you know i wanted a a substantial one
and ideally you know it's over three
floors you need your fire doors you need
your regulations
um
so yeah i switched strategies i went
back to the the brr um
found another three bed uh similarly
attached house um it'd actually been
half finished so there was actually a
builder who owned it um and he was doing
extensive renovation works on there
he was doing a loft conversion
moving some walls downstairs and he'd
obviously run out of cash so uh
i put a cheeky offer in and the offer
was accepted unfortunately
when it came to exchange he pulled
he'd obviously come into some cash and
wanted to complete the project himself
so
you know that was a lesson for me yeah i
uh
i learned that you can't always win in
property sometimes you have to lose yeah
and also you can't be emotionally
attached it's about a particular
property because that that can happen we
say never be at ease until you've got
the keys
um so you lost
yeah we lost that one yet yeah and then
what happened next um so i started
looking again
uh put some offers in on different
properties wasn't really getting
anywhere with them um
you know they weren't getting accepted
but i just kept going um in the end i
put an offer in on a three bed uh semi
detached house it didn't need too much
work it was just um you know it was very
dated it needed a fresh lick of paint um
a lot of tidying up uh and that one went
through which was really good
uh that the purchase price on that one
was 250
and that's two years ago
at the time i didn't know about bridging
finance or or a lot of you know raising
capital uh angel investors so i put a
mortgage on it
mortgaged the property done the refurb
on it
and the property is now worth 330. so it
means when we can remortgage that one
early next year we can pull a big lump
out of that so you know there's hardly
hardly any money left in the deal that's
incredible and i think the property is
where it's one of those things isn't it
where um even if you don't know
everything there is to know about
property i know when you did some of the
online courses yeah 2020 he said you
almost felt overwhelmed with shall i do
this this this oh my goodness but you
don't have to know everything about
everything to make money in property
because
even if you just buy a house and you
don't know what you're doing it can it
probably will go up in value exactly you
know but you didn't know what you're
doing you had you had some knowledge you
had the ability to take some action you
went through the rejections and the
hardships so you bought it for 250 it's
now worth 3 30 and then you'll refinance
on it two years later yeah nearly all of
your money yep that's incredible talk to
me about the chapel on the beach because
that one is um i know very exciting so
yeah this is uh this is a
property that we've had an offer
accepted on um we're looking to push it
through really really quickly
so it's in a prime location it's three
meters to the beach
it's a converted chapel
uh two bed
uh two bed and a storeroom now the
storeroom is also really interesting
for service accommodation you know you
want something unique
um so i think we could turn that into
like a kids cave
storage area for kite surfers
we'll do something creative with it
but yes right on the uh right on the
beach right in a prime location it's got
all the uh period features the glass
windows the beams
so yeah it should be how much you paying
for it so that's two three seven two
three seven and what's the vision then
how are you gonna rent it out how are
you gonna make money so it's gonna be
done as a holiday let um which is really
good
three meters from the beach it is
literally on the beach
that's not even away from the beach like
three meters the beach is your garden
wow two three seven that sounds quite
cheap it is at least
999 years on the lease yeah
it's actually been fully refurbished uh
brand new kitchen brand new bathroom
which for us is you know it's really
good because we've not we've always
bought one that needs loads and loads of
work yeah um so now are you going to
just rent this straight out as a holiday
let them know the plan uh should be
serviced accommodation yeah it's a
holiday there and how much do you think
you'll make on it
so to get the mortgage on it um
i needed to get two independent
companies to give me a low medium and
high valuation on there
so the high season we're looking at
twelve to thirteen hundred pound a week
wow uh the low season is around six
fifty to seven fifty so a really good
number so it'll be a good few thousand a
month then definitely all year through
um and what will that do to your um to
your income because at the moment how
much you make at the moment from your
property income so our income at the
minute is around 2500 per month yeah
that's from the three bed that we've got
the hmo or
and one of the flats that we're
refurbishing yeah and the hmo that's an
interesting one talk to me about it give
me the figures in the story on that
so the hmo is really interesting
it's fully compliant as a hmo
it's got all the fire doors meets all
the regulations it's a four bed three
story
with the potential to turn it into a
five bed it's not actually being rented
as a hmo at the minute tell me why um
so there was a lovely couple in the area
i actually contacted my sister on social
media
and uh their house had been struck by
lightening believe it or not
and uh they were looking for somewhere
to rent short term just for 12 months so
they could be close to the kid's school
and it was the perfect location for them
so we agreed they could have it for 12
months and then
the plan is when they move out at the
end of this year and this problem is
where you're like you're kidding me all
out you've got fire doors
so we hadn't furnished it so we were
just about to furnish it but you've got
the fire doors and the fire doors
already in there yeah so you've got it
all ready for html about to be about
ready to be furnished and then exactly
from this lady saying my house has been
struck by lightning what what was the um
the reason for
for that was that like a commercial
reason or was that purely just because
you wanted to help no you know it wasn't
a commercial um commercial reason at all
we could definitely get more money for
it as a hmo
you know i think this business it can't
just be about money it has to be about
people as well and for us in the local
area
um how do we give something back
um so for me yeah i guess it was more of
a more of a decision based on the the
need of the people yeah that's great and
i know about six months ago you enrolled
onto the full academy um
the online courses um what was the
reason for that and and how's that been
so far and
what's happened since
yeah so it was really good you know my
intentions were already to were always
to do the live events um
i've done the online ones but it's just
not the same you're just not in that
you know i think the best way to
describe it is the network and and the
energy it's almost a family of property
investors um
and i think not only learning from from
you guys and and the trainers
and the mentors but also from from
everybody else with all the different
strategies
so for me it was a it was a no-brainer
yeah and i guess as well if you put a
little bit into yourself
then what you've got left can go much
further in property right exactly
exactly and you've got access to the
best power team mortgage brokers and as
you say people network to do deals with
yeah um so what's your biggest you
you've learned
as you've gone along to some extent
you've done some training you're in
lockdown you know you've been in the
property business now for a few years
what lessons have been the biggest
learning curves would you say over the
years
it's a really good question i think
you know to be successful in property a
lot of people see success don't they but
they don't see all the hard work and the
knockbacks and and the failures
and and the graft that you put in yeah
to enable you to get there now i guess
for me you know i've got quite a
supportive partner um
obviously a supportive father he's
actually in business with me now joint
venture 50 50. which is great yeah
but yeah for me it's all the graph that
you put in you know doing a lot of the
work yourself even just the paperwork um
we tend to be really hands-on so all the
refurbs we're just about to ourselves um
you know apart from the gas and the
electrics um
yeah so for me just hard work pays off
it's the craft yeah so putting the work
in um you think it's really important i
think you're right as well because
if you want to make a lot of money in
property you need to treat it like a
business if you treat it like a side
hustle then you'll get sideways and
results you know you've certainly taken
it on um properly tripped like a
business what i've been um what's your
favorite property then what's been
out of your little portfolio so i think
that
i think my favorite one at the minute
discount in the chapel because it's not
gone for it at the minute um is the
freehold block of two masonettes we're
currently doing and what's the burst
price on that so the purchase price was
300 on that one yeah um
now it's completed the top one is
refurbed uh and rented it out as of this
week so incredible and what do you rate
on that uh thousand pound per month
per unit per unit it's going to be 2 000
pounds a month you bought it for 300 and
you've added presumably you've added
some value
yeah so i think we'll end up spending
just over 60 on it yeah um and the end
value will be about
220 per unit wow so 440
so what have you got there profit wise
you're talking sort of about 80 grand
again
yeah yeah which is really good it's not
bad it's about 80 grand in one deal like
that and then on top of it have 2 000
pounds a month rent coming in exactly
and of course we've got the freehold as
well yeah so we're going to split the
titles on that one
um russell's actually very kindly give
me a solicitor who i was speaking to
yesterday you can do that which is
fantastic again part of being on the
academy part of having that uh poutine
so what would you say to somebody then
that's wanting to get into property
there's maybe like yourself you know
come from full-time work um
working full-time hasn't got loads of
time hasn't got loads of money
and wants to get into property what
would you say advice you would give to
somebody wanting to start just do it get
stuck in um you know if i can do it
anybody can do it it's just time it
depends how much you want it doesn't it
yeah
you know if you dedicated it for me it's
a way of building you know long-term
wealth
i think i'm quite lucky i'm in a job you
know i really enjoy it um i don't want
to leave that job yeah just getting that
job right i am still in that job yeah
even though you're making a full-time
income from property you know you've
stayed you've stayed in your job is that
just because you enjoy it i enjoy my job
yeah i think i'm very fortunate to do
that but there was a point you know
there was a point where i thought how am
i going to be able to still
stay and work
but also scale the property business
and to do that i was very fortunate that
my dad decided to to join the business
with me yeah
so he is very much looking after all of
the day-to-day business all of the
operations
maintenance
yeah which is really good and that
allows me to focus
you know on not only my full-time job
but also i'm finding new deals
new opportunities
what are you looking for next then
what's the plan this year so the plan
this year is to get that chapel over the
line i want to get that up and running
as soon as possible hopefully catch the
uh the last of the summer months
and then we've got a viewing on saturday
actually to um
to potentially look at a land deal
which is currently one dwelling on their
derelict building
and we think we can split split it and
build two separate units incredible um
you know really profitable as well uh
done up value for each will be around
600
um and the purchase price is 500 for the
unit
very very nice which is good yeah very
very nice so what's the reason then
what's your motivation because you're
clearly a driven person you know you had
your job and then you were doing
university at the weekends talking about
business you're now in business you're a
property entrepreneur and property
investor also have a job
working long hours making very good
money what's the what's the strongest
reason for doing this
yeah i think for me is i'm the type of
person that has to be busy um you ask my
partner i'm terrible when i'm bored i
just annoy everyone i need to be doing
something but i think really is you know
to build that long-term wealth and
stability for myself and my family yeah
would you prefer that do you prefer
holiday let service accommodation html
what excites you more
service accommodation why is that
i just like the idea of it you know i
think there's so much opportunity with
it
hmo you need
really four beds
you could do it with a three if you want
but
you're just renting a bedroom out i
think it gives you an opportunity to be
quite unique and creative yes um you
know a chapel is is something that will
really sell oh yeah i'll be staying
there 100 percent yeah if it's whatever
like it was today i think you'll be
getting very good money what about what
would you prefer biorefurbish for
finance or why to let
buy refurbished refinance
why is that because i can keep recycling
the money um you know you can put it in
you get the work done you pull it out
and
you know you can almost then end up with
a top market
um top valuation because you've done all
the work you know it's almost a brand
new building at the end yeah um you know
you take the worst house and turn it
into the best house on the street right
and that's very much what we've done
with the masonettes
all right what about what excites you
more cash flow or capital appreciation
capital appreciation interesting go on
why is that um because at the minute i'm
still in full-time work
you know i'm an engineering manager i
don't earn bad money
so for me it's that capital appreciation
that turns into cash flow yeah right and
even lockdown interesting actually
you'll probably remember this because in
um around about this time two years ago
uh beginning of june i think it was
actually june the 8th all the newspapers
were saying property market's going to
crash and i did a youtube video and said
actually i think it's going to go up and
and it did that's right
and everybody was two years ago everyone
was doom and gloom but the market has
rocketed um did you expect that to
happen no not in the way it has even
though i thought it would
yeah i expected it to go up but not by
this level yeah um you know there's
still a lot of talk now property prices
are gonna crash i just can't see it um
you know especially in this country
there may be certain areas where it does
but there's a housing shortage
absolutely that all the properties that
i've had yeah have rented out before
we've even advertised yeah now people
are asking me people are paying over the
over the odds for them
because they just can't get them and if
they do they're usually subpar yeah um
exciting great so what will be your
final words of advice words of wisdom um
for all the people listening here
so i think words of wisdom
if you want to do property
do your research
make sure you've got the knowledge get
some training and then take that leap
forward um get stuck in choose your
strategy and really just go for it
yeah love it well thank you so much
lovely thank you
[Music]